we of course are starting with the story
in texas it's been the lead story for
the past four days a flooding disaster
in houston is getting worse with every
drop of rain that falls and guess what
it is pouring again this morning
rescue crews are working virtually
nonstop pulling out stranded people and
taking them to safety the confirmed
death toll is three but that is likely
to rise the official rainfall totals are
staggering 48 inches that's four feet of
rain in friendswood southeast of houston
41 inches in baytown 36 in kenwood and
32 inches in downtown houston the
shelters they are overflowing with
evacuees nora o'donnell is outside the
george r brown convention center in
downtown houston where thousands spent
the night nora good morning
good morning and it's not just raining
this morning it's been raining all night
long we are standing just in front of
houston's main evacuation center let me
tell you it is packed with people we've
been reporting that the official
capacity is 5 000 but cbs news has
learned there are
921 people that stayed here last night
many of them without beds they told us
they only had 5 000 cots so imagine
what's going on inside emergency
responders have now rescued more than 6
000 people as you know president trump
is headed here to texas this morning to
check on the relief operation his first
step is stop is going to be in corpus
christi now that is near the area where
hurricane harvey made landfall harvey is
still a tropical storm it is spinning
off the gulf coast and listen to this it
could make a second landfall tomorrow
just east of houston mark strassman is
here mark that's the huge concern
already straining these rescue efforts
is this could be coming back for more i
think about this nora the reality is
that no one knows for certain already
how many people are missing how many
people evacuated themselves and how many
people still need to be rescued harvey
is shaping up as one of the great flood
disasters in u.s history
as soaking rains fell mercilessly across
southeast texas rescues like this one
played out across houston
emergency responders waded through flood
waters going door to door helping anyone
in need of evacuation
first floors put in
we moved a bunch of stuff upstairs
overnight there was a new flood of
people looking for a dry place to stay
this is going to be a very long event
you're going to get frustrated you're
going to be tired your routine is going
to be is going to be disrupted for weeks
we are striving for a new normal here
but the new normal for the nearly 7
million people in the houston area is
the never ending site of flood waters
officials say parts of this city will be
submerged for days this is if not the
largest has to be categorized as one of
the largest
disasters
america has ever faced
evacuations remain priority number one
but with law enforcement stretched thin
city officials also worry about looting
in this city we can rescue you and in
this city we can also arrest you and
what that means no looting allowed
despite this massive rescue effort some
people still wait for help
on monday jason garcia watched coast
guard choppers lift people out of his
flooded neighborhood i can't make it
over there so
anything i can do to help much
appreciated garcia eventually found the
evacuation spot but he said about 70
others were also waiting to be rescued
there's a lot of kids
a lot of women
so
we ain't going anytime soon
all 12 000 available texas national
guardsmen have been activated and help
is pouring in from across the country
but the rescued need places to stay and
the biggest shelter in houston is
already packed full this is going to be
a shelter until everybody here has a
place to go which could be some time
given the scope of this could be some
time
i mentioned that emergency officials
have had to focus on both search and
rescue and law and order houston police
have arrested at least seven people for
looting after they allegedly attempted
to impersonate emergency teams all right
mark straussman thank you